in this video we will be studying the
clotting factors after watching this
video I will encourage you to watch the
second part of this video which
describes the coagulation pathways I
will leave a link to that video in the
screen right now and also it will be in
the description of this video now as you
know there are 13 clotting factors
number 1 to 13 but only actually 12 are
there because the factor number 6 is
missing and we will discuss that later
so let's get started coming to the
factor number 1 factor number one is the
fibrin region and the source of religion
is liver so all those diseases which
affect the functioning of the liver
decreases the concentration of
revolution in the plasma which will
subsequently affect the copulation
pathways a factor number 2 factor number
two is the prothrombin and source of the
growth robbing is also the liver a
proton beam is alpha 2 globulin of
plasma concentration approximately 15
milligrams per deciliter and this is one
of the most important plasma proteins
which are involved in the coagulation
cascade
prothrombin splits into number of small
proteins one of the important protein is
the thrombin which converts fibrinogen
into fibrin coming to the factor number
3 factor number three is the
thromboplastin or the tissue factor and
source of the faction number 3 Rd
platelets and the endothelium of the
blood vessels now this factor is
involved in the initiation of the
intrinsic pathway whenever there is
trauma to the blood vessel the factor
number 3 is released which starts the
intrinsic pathway of blood coagulation
factor
for now this is the calcium and calcium
is the most important ion which is
involved in the coagulation pathways it
is involved in almost all of the
reactions of the intrinsic and the
extrinsic pathways sparing some of them
calcium is used in almost all of these
reactions factor number five factor
number five is also known as the labile
factor also known as the pro accelerant
I forgot to mention the source of the
calcium the calcium is derived from the
absorption of bone and also from the
gastrointestinal tract absorption coming
to the factor number five source this is
derived from the liver and the platelets
now as factor number six this is
important thing to remember that factor
number six is not there in the
coagulation factors factor number six is
not resin because earlier factor number
five a that is activated factor five
Falls was known as factor number six now
it is designated as five a so factor
number six is unassigned coming to the
factor number seven a factor number
seven is the stable factor also known as
the pro converting also known as serum
prothrombin conversion accelerator and
source of this factor is the liver
factor number eight factor number eight
is the anti mephitic factor a and source
of this factor is the endothelium of the
blood vessels the deficiency of factor
number eight results in classic
haemophilia factor number nine it is
known as the Xmas factor also known as
anti hemophilic factor B and source of
factor number nine is the liver coming
to the factor number ten one of the most
important factors or in coagulation also
known as stored factor or the steward
power factor and source of this factor
number ten is the liver factor number
eleven factor number eleven is
the plasma thromboplastin and dissident
and source of this factor is liver
factor number 12 factor number 12 is
also known as the Hickman factor and
these factors the nine the eleven and
the twelve are involved exclusively in
the intrinsic pathway of the blood
coagulation and source of the human
factor is also the liver coming to the
factor number thirteen October 13 is a
very important factor and it is known as
the fibrin stabilizing factor and what
this factor does is basically it
stabilizes the fibrin monomers that are
formed after the fibrin hojin is
converted into fibrin because initially
after conversion of fibrinogen into
fibrin these fibers are not bound
strongly so the factor number thirteen
produces covalent bonds in between them
and form the strong fibrin mesh so this
was a short description of the
coagulation factors after watching this
video please watch the second part of
the video which describes the
coagulation pathways in detail if you
find this video informative make sure to
hit the like button below and also
subscribe to our channel for the further
videos